So this class and the next
class and a half are going to be
about Fisher's theory of present
value and the interest rate,
and then we're going to move to
uncertainty.
So up until now what we've done
is we found out first,
if you know the whole economic
system, how to solve for
equilibrium.
To figure out from the
primitives of people's tastes,
their impatience,
the technology,
the economy,
how to figure out the real rate
of interest if provided there is
no uncertainty in the world and
people can forecast what is
going to happen later.
We've found that once you've
done that,
the price of every asset,
if people are rational and
looking forward to the future,
the price of every asset is
going to be the present value of
the future payments of the
asset.
So if you think of the payments
as real payments,
which is what Fisher always
recommended, you discount by the
real interest rate.
If you think of them as cash
payments then you discount by
the nominal interest rate.
So every asset corresponds to
its present value of its
dividends either discounted by
the real rate or the nominal
rate.
Now, this thinking is
surprisingly powerful and leads
you to unexpected conclusions.
So the next two classes is
about that.
Mostly I'm going to talk about
Social Security,
but I'm going to begin today by
finishing off a subject we
didn't quite get through last
time.
So you see, if you realize that
the price of every asset is just
the present value of its
dividends,
and you also suppose you know
what the dividends are going to
be and what the future interest
rates are going to be,
then it follows that you know
what the price of the asset is
going to be,
not just today,
but next year,
and the year after and the year
after that.
So your theory of asset pricing
today,
which was based on the
assumption that you can forecast
the future,
necessarily implies the theory
of asset pricing in the future.
So you can tell something about
how asset prices are going to
change,
and of course you can also test
the theory because the theory
implicitly is forecasting
something about the future,
and therefore you can test the
theory.
So let's just take a couple
examples that are in the notes.
So we said at the top,
if you can read it,
I hope it's not too small--I
want to move a little quickly so
I could be writing this on the
board,
but if you can see it and you
look at the top line it says
that the present value of the
assets is just the discount of
future dividends.
So maybe I'll start one line
up, actually,
in these notes.
So if you look in the middle
here the present value today,
suppose you have an asset,
maybe I'm going to write on the
board after all.
Present value of an asset,
suppose you know the dividends
are going to be paying C (1),
C (2), and maybe C (T) at the
end.
Those are the dividends that
are going to be paid,
and you can ask what the
present value of the asset is
today, PV_0 today,
0.
Well, Fisher would say if you
think of these as nominal cash
flows he would say what you need
to do is you need to find out
the price of zeros.
So you recall that Fisher said
that you could let
pi_1 = the price today
of 1 dollar at time 1,
and the price today
pi_T = the price today
of 1 dollar time T.
It's the price today of 1
dollar in the future.
These were the crucial prices
that Fisher said that you should
always look for.
He said that you can always
find these prices,
pi_1 through
pi_T by deriving them
from the yield curve.
So every morning everybody
looks at the yield curve,
all financial analysts,
they look at the prices of
bonds traded in the market.
The simplest form is you get a
yield curve in the newspapers.
You deduce from the yield curve
what these present values
pi_1,
pi_T are,
and that allows you to price
any asset like this one simply
by multiplying by
pi_1,
pi_2 and at the end
by pi_T.
So that's step 1.
But then step 2,
we said, was that once you've
got these prices you can figure
out the forwards.
So the forwards are going to be
1 i_t,
so 1 i_t that's by
definition the interest from t
to t 1 that would be agreed
today.
It's not the interest rate
that's going to prevail from
time t,
it's the interest rate that
people today at time 0 would
agree to pay between time t and
time t 1.
So that, of course,
has to just equal
pi_t over pi_t
1,
because everybody today
recognizes that the cost of a
dollar time t is pi_t,
and the cost of a dollar at
time t 1 is pi_t 1.
So the tradeoff between t and t
1 that's effectively what an
interest rate does is it trades
off money at one time for
another time.
It has to be this ratio.
So today people would agree on
1 i_t^(F),
forward, as the forward rate.
Now, you add to that the
assumption that everybody is
certain about the future,
assume perfect forecasting.
So I don't have to actually
assume people are right in their
forecasting.
I have to assume that they are
completely sure of their
forecasting.
So if they're completely sure
of their forecasting then
everybody must foresee that they
think they're sure that the
future interest rate that will
prevail at time t is also equal
to this number.
So we can then rewrite this
price.
Hello.
We can rewrite this price as 1
i_0^(F),
forward;
instead of pi_2,
pi_2 is just going to
be 1 over (1 i_0^(F))
times (1 i_1^(F)),
and time pi_T is just
going to be 1 over (1
i_0^(F)) times (1
i_1^(F)) ...
times (1 i_t 1^(F)).
Because using the fact that (1
i_t) is pi_t
divided by pi_t 1 I
just multiply pi_1
divided by pi_2 times
pi_2 divided by
pi_0 etcetera.
If I take pi_1
divided by pi_0 times
etcetera I'm going to get
exactly this formula.
So pi_0 is always 1,
by the way.
So if I want to take
pi_1 it's just going
to be 1 over (1
i_0^(F)).
If I want to take
pi_2 I can always do
this,
pi_2,
and so this is going to equal
so pi_2 is going to
be 1 over (1 i^(F)_0)
times 1 over (1
i^(F)_1) etcetera.
And pi_3,
if I want to do pi_3,
I just multiply by
pi_3 over
pi_2 and so that's
equal to 1 over (1
i^(F)_0) times 1 over
(1 i^(F)_1) times 1
over (1 i^(F)_2).
So instead of multiplying by
the pis I may as well take the
product of the forwards.
It's exactly the same thing.
So the present value has this
simple formula,
but this is a formula that
holds at every time t if you're
totally confident of your
predictions of the Cs and of the
future interest rates.
This is where we ended last
time, basically with this
formula.
The key that you had to use in
the problem set was to realize
if you're totally confident now
about the future you have to be
totally confident about doing
this calculation in the future.
So PV_1 is going to
be basically the same
calculation.
So what's going to happen at
time 1?
After you've gone down 1 year
you've finished with this
interest rate and you're looking
at everything 1 year later.
So I may as well write the
PV_1 here and that's
going to equal C (2)--
let's put it a little bit
lower--PV_1 is going
to equal the same C (2) as
before,
but now a year later.
So it's just going to be 1
i^(F)_1 C (T),
and I don't need the 1
i^(F)_0 anymore.
(1 i^(F)_1) times ...
(1 i^(F)_T-1).
So it's exactly the same
formula 1 year later,
and 1 year later you no longer
have to worry about the interest
rate.
That time already passed.
So you just drop this at every
time and you write the same
formula, and of course you drop
C (1) because that's all
finished.
So the price at time 1 is just
what's left except you've
chopped off the 1
i^(F)_0 everywhere.
So to write that the same way,
so PV_0 (I can write
it the same way) =,
PV_0 = what?
It's going to equal the
interest payment you get,
C (1), not the interest,
the dividend you get,
the cash flow you get plus
PV_1 divided by 1
i^(F)_0.
So this is a very important
formula.
So why is that?
Well, it's a proof by formula,
but another way of saying it is
that PV_0,
when you get the asset at time
0 it gives you a cash flow at
time 1,
and then of course looked at
from the point of view of time 1
you've got all the future cash
flows,
but that's just what
PV_1 is.
So basically the bond is going
to give you a cash flow at time
1,
and then the right to cash
flows in the future,
but this right to cash flows in
the future at time 1 is worth
PV_1.
So it's like you've got all
this money at time 1 and so to
get the value at time 0 you have
to discount it back again.
So this is a very famous and
important formula which I want
to pause a second and think
about.
So there's a controversy today
called marking to market.
Does anybody know what that
controversy is about?
What does marking to market
mean?
Yep?
Student: I believe that
it means that corporations and
their accounting rules are
currently required to value
their assets at what they would
fetch in the market if they were
to sell them.
Prof: Right,
but you know that they've been
relieved of this responsibility
recently.
Student: No,
I didn't know that.
Prof: Well,
so they've been relieved of
this responsibility lately.
Now, why have they been
relieved of it?
Because the thought was that
the market was so panicked in
the crisis that the price that
they could fetch by selling
their things really had nothing
to do with the value.
So we're going to come back to
whether that was a good idea
that Congress passed under
tremendous pressure.
What is the point of marking to
market?
So let's suppose that you
really could anticipate the
future and everybody was right
about it.
The market price then would
really be PV_0 today,
and it really would be
PV_1 tomorrow,
because if the interest rate's
do actually turn out to be what
everybody expects,
and everybody's completely
confident of their expectation,
then as we saw the prices would
have to be this today and this
tomorrow,
otherwise there'd be an
arbitrage.
You could make money for sure,
or think you could make money
for sure.
So if you're marking to market
what are you going to mark as
the profits?
Are you going to say the profit
at time 1 is--so what is profit?
If I had some room I'd put this
somewhere.
How would you define profit?
I'll get rid of this.
I think we've got this straight.
So how would you define profit
at time 1?
What would you write?
So let's say that this isn't a
bond.
It's an investment.
You paid a bunch of money at
time 0, maybe PV_0 and
in the future your investment is
going to pay off some money.
Maybe it was a project you
invested in.
Maybe you bought a bunch of
stuff and you're selling it in
the future and getting this
money.
Maybe you bought a bond which
is paying these coupons.
Whatever it is these are the
cash flows of the project,
and now of course your
investors are very curious.
In year 1, they want to know
what profit have you made,
how are you doing?
So what's a number that you'd
think of giving?
What's the first number you'd
think of telling them?
Yep?
Student: Maybe the first
cash flow payout.
Prof: So you might think
of saying, C (1).
That's the cash you've gotten.
So all these people could see
you've gotten C (1).
That's your revenue,
and I'm assuming this cash flow
is net of expenses.
So you could say here's your
revenue you got at time 1,
C (1).
Is that your profit?
If it were, people would then
look and they'd say,
"Well, we got profit of C
(1) and we put an investment in
of PV_0 so is that the
rate of return?
Is that my rate of return?"
Yeah?
Student: Can we do
PV_1 - PV_0
and add it here?
Prof: So he's exactly
right.
I'm going to repeat what he
said, but I'm going to take
longer to say it.
This idea of writing C (1) over
PV_0 is actually what
many people try to say is their
profit, but it's a bad number
for profit.
Now, if in period 1 you stopped
marking to market,
and you had no idea,
you didn't have to report this
number PV_1,
I mean, you didn't know what it
was or you didn't have to report
it,
what else could you report but
C (1) over PV_0 as the
profit?
So marking to market,
you see, is intimately
connected to how you report
profit.
So if you don't mark to market
you don't know,
you don't have to declare what
the value of the assets are that
are left.
All you would do when you
describe your profits is you'd
say C (1) and people would,
of course, in their heads,
in fact they wouldn't do it in
their heads,
you'd tell them,
"Our rate of return was C
(1) over PV_0,"
but why might that be a very
misleading number?
Well, his point is it could
well be that C (1) is a very
high number.
You've got a lot of cash flow
this period, but he said it may
turn out that PV_1 is
a terrible number.
You may have gotten a lot of
cash flow, but there's nothing
left going forward.
So he doesn't think that's a
very good measure of profit.
So he's suggesting why not
report profit as C (1)
PV_1 - PV_0.
Now, suppose you did that?
So he's saying,
look, you've got a certain
amount of cash but the assets
that you had also changed value
and you ought to include that in
your profit.
So what if you did that?
What would your rate of return
be?
And suppose PV_0 and
PV_1 were calculated
as this?
And so you divided this by
PV_0 what would that
equal?
What number would I get if I
did that?
I can't hear.
What?
Somebody speak up.
Student:
i^(F)_0.
Prof: Yes.
This would just be
i^(F)_0,
and you get the rate of return
that you're expecting to get.
Now, how do I know that's
i^(F)_0?
Because I multiplied by
PV_0 to this side,
then I moved that
PV_0 to the other
side.
That gives me 1
i_0^(F)
PV_0,
then I divide by that 1
i^(F)_0 and put it
down here,
and that's this formula.
So that is what you would get,
i^(F)_0.
And you see that's what you
should expect to get because you
haven't done anything great.
You've got a cash flow.
You've got these cash flows at
the beginning.
You paid a fair price for them
and next period everybody
forecast that the values were
going to go to PV_1,
and so it can't be that you're,
you know--
this was an investment you made.
You put your money in.
You bought this bond.
You could sell the bond now at
time 1 after having obtained the
cash flows.
It better be that your rate of
return is the market interest
rate of return otherwise there'd
be some arbitrage,
and in fact it is.
So if you can compute all the
present values properly,
the only fair thing to do--this
is not a great investment.
Even if C (1) is a huge amount
of money it's only huge because
PV_1 is a low amount
of money.
Because it has to be that the
profit every period,
the rate of profit,
is exactly equal to the
interest rate,
because everything is always
priced at its present value.
So it's a simple concept which
somehow takes a long time to
grasp.
It just seems to people
that--here's the money that's
come in.
That's the cash you can count
in your hands.
You've got it in your hands.
That's the number you should
talk about as profit,
but of course of the money
coming into your hands--there's
this other hidden thing.
The stuff that you own has
suddenly fallen in value
compared to what it was before.
You're really not putting the
firm in any better position than
it was before.
You just earned your normal
rate of return.
So you can see why,
to give a fair description of
how people are doing,
the law was written,
evolved to the point where
people were forced not to just
say C (1),
they were forced to
declare--mark to market,
and add PV_1 -
PV_0 to their profit
to get a real rate of return,
to get a more revealing rate of
return.
And so what happened in the
crisis is this PV_1
became such a horribly low
number that if you plug that
into this formula you get
PV_1 is a really low
number compared to
PV_0.
You get a giant negative here.
It would look like the rate of
return was terrible.
Everyone would panic and think
the firms had fallen apart.
So especially the banks were
the ones who didn't want to do
this,
and so Congress didn't want the
public to be panicked so it
simply said,
"Okay, forget about it.
We're going to not hold you to
writing PV_1 anymore
because we can't count anybody
figuring out what it is,
and so you don't have to tell
us that.
You just have to tell us
this," which happens to be
a good number for the banks,
but that doesn't mean the banks
are actually doing well because
the assets they hold have been
collapsing in value.
Yeah?
Student: Does that
>
say that assuming there's no
arbitrage opportunity if a firm
pays out a high dividend its
stock should go down?
Prof: Yes, right.
That's exactly what it says and
that's what does happen.
So you always talk about the
price, ex-dividend and stuff
like that, precisely that.
So if a firm pays a bigger than
usual dividend,
if it suddenly decides it's
going to pay itself a gigantic
dividend then the price of the
firm is going to go down,
exactly, because there's less
value in the firm.
You've paid it out here instead
of keeping it into the firm.
So this is a very simple idea,
but it's very easy to get
confused about.
Are there any questions about
it?
So let's do an example of it.
The most basic example of it is
the premium bond.
So we talked about this before,
So let's say you have
PV_0 = 5 divided by
1.10 5 divided by 1.10
[correction: squared]
(maybe this was exactly the
problem set,
I can't remember) 105 divided
by 1.10 [correction:
to the T].
So in other words the interest
rate--I did that wrong--squared
and T.
So the forwards,
in other words,
1 i^(F)_t (small t) =
1 .10 for all t,
so all the forwards are 10
percent.
The bond is paying--I can't
remember which one I did.
Let's do 20 here.
I'm going to make it a premium
bond, so it's paying 20.
So what's going to be the price
of the bond?
Well, in the first period it
looks like you get this
incredible profit.
The interest rate is 10 percent.
You've paid some present value
and you've made 20.
You've made a number much
bigger--so the price of this
thing, by the way what was the
home work problem?
What were the numbers?
What was the interest rate?
Did somebody do the homework?
I did assign a homework on a
premium bond,
right?
The interest rate was 5 percent
and the coupon was 10,
was that what it was?
What?
What was it?
What was the homework problem?
Student: 8 and 6.
Prof: 8 and 6.
So this was 8 percent.
Might as well do this one,
6 here, yeah,
6 percent, and this one was 8.
So what was the price
PV_0?
What was PV_0?
You've done this homework
problem, right?
Does anyone remember what
number they got?
Ben, do you remember the number?
No.
I'm counting on my trusty class
here to provide me all the
numbers.
It was what?
Student: 108.4.
Prof: Was that what it
was, 108.4?
That's all?
This was the price just 108.4?
So 108.4, right.
That's a high price.
So it's way above par.
This is a bond that's worth
much more than 100.
Why?
Because the interest rate is 6
percent, but the coupon is 8 so
this is called a premium bond.
So if you look at the first
year the rate of return on the
first year is 8 over 108.4.
Now, is that more than 6
percent?
It is way more than 6 percent,
8 over 108.4.
It is way more than 6 percent
because 7 percent of this is
going to be less than 8.
So it's more than 7 percent,
so this is greater than 7
percent, and so it's certainly
bigger than 6 percent.
So it sure looks like at the
end of the first year like this
bond was an ace bond.
That's the kind of calls you
used to get.
You still sometimes do get them
if you're a wealthy person and
you actually answer calls like
this,
which you don't of course,
but you can get some cold call
from a sales person saying,
"We've got a fund and look
how well it's doing.
On this much investment last
year we got payments of 8
dollars.
That's more than 7 percent,
and look, everybody can see the
interest rate is only 6 percent
and we did better than 7
percent.
We're doing great.
Why don't you invest in our
fund?"
But actually,
what the salesman hasn't told
you is that the value of his
assets has gone down.
So the present value
PV_1 must be less than
PV_0,
because we know from this
formula, the formula right up
here,
that 6 percent is going to be
the cash flow over
PV_0 which is more
than 7 percent plus this
difference,
and this difference,
therefore, is going to have to
be negative.
So what he didn't tell you was
that the fund lost value even
though the first payment was
better than 6 percent,
the market rate of interest.
So that's the first example.
Now, let's do another example.
Suppose you have a--let's see
if I can write on this board.
There's a famous trade called
the carry trade.
Now, suppose the
forwards--suppose 1
i^(F)_0 is 2 percent,
sort of like now,
the 1 year yield,
and 1 i^(F)_t is 5
percent,
for t greater than 1?
So if you have a 1 year bond
it's going to pay--well,
let's say it's 2 percent and
this is equal to 1 --can you see
this or it's disappearing.
So let's make the first two of
them be 2 percent,
and this is for t greater than
or equal to 3.
So the interest rate is 2
percent and then it's going to
jump to 5 percent.
All right, so if you have a
2-year bond,
a 2-year Treasury,
a 2-year bond might pay 2 and
102 and the present value of
this equals 100,
the present value of the 2-year
bond.
But now maybe you've got a
longer bond that's a 5-year bond
which pays coupons 4,
4,4, 104, so this is a 5-year
bond,
and maybe its price is close to
100.
Actually, I haven't worked out
the number so you're going to
have to do that in the next
problem set.
So is it possible,
so I'll ask it this way,
is it possible for this coupon
to be higher 4,
4,4, 4,4 and yet still have a
present value of 100 than this
one which is 2 and 102?
Could you have a higher coupon
and yet the same present value
of 100 on a longer bond than on
a shorter bond?
How could this bond have a
higher coupon and sell for the
same price as this bond?
Yep?
Student: You're losing
money on the assets you put on
the principal value because you
get it in a later period
>
Prof: So the point is
you're discounting the first two
payments by 2 percent a year,
but you're discounting these
payments by 5 percent a year.
So these things are going to be
much worse than they look.
And so even though the 4s are
all better,
this 100, you know,
it's 4,4, 4,4,
4 100, that 100,
not to mention these three last
4s are getting discounted by a
lot.
So that 104 is going to be
worth less than 100 back,
you know, it's going to be
worth less.
So that's why these things are
going to go down a lot more than
you think.
They're going to be worth less
than 100.
So even though these things are
better than the 2 percent rate
of return--
this bond does great at the
beginning,
but does poorly thereafter,
because in the beginning it's
paying 4 percent when the
interest rate is 2 percent,
but later it's paying 4 when
the interest rate is 5 percent,
so clearly you could have some
situation like that.
So what's the carry trade?
The carry trade is you buy the
long bond and sell short the
short bond, so the lower
maturity--too many shorts--the
lower maturity bond.
So this is the,
let's say, 5 year and 2 year.
Buy the 5-year bond and sell
short the 2-year.
The word, sell short,
is different from the word,
short bond.
So you buy the 5-year bond and
you sell the 2-year bond.
They both cost you 100,
so what's happening at the
beginning?
You're making 4 dollars and
you're only having to pay 2
dollars.
It looks like you're making a
profit for nothing,
right?
So that's the carry trade.
You buy long bonds with a high
rate of interest.
You sell short bonds with low
coupons and it looks like you're
making a profit.
But in fact,
what's really happening?
So just repeat what you were
saying before,
but now in this context.
What's really happening?
Student: You're paying
off that difference,
the loss of the value of your
assets.
You're not getting back as much
as you would if you had just
bought the 2-year bond.
Prof: Right.
So the long bond you got a cash
flow of 4 the first year.
You had to pay 2 because you
sold the 2-year short,
right?
So you're up 2 dollars,
but the thing that you owe now
at the end of the first year,
since the interest rate is 2
percent,
the next interest rate is 2
the 2-year bond is still worth
100.
So your negative position is
still worth 100,
but this positive position now,
these 4,
4s and 4s it looks worse than
it did before because you've
moved up the yield curve.
Instead of having two 2 percent
years you only got one 2 percent
year before you shift into the 5
percents which is worse and
worse.
So what's going to happen is
you're going to get a positive
cash flow at the beginning,
it looks like positive profits
right at the beginning.
That C (1), the net C (1) looks
really good,
but right after that,
the value of your assets is
going to plummet compared to
your liabilities,
because now all of a sudden
you're discounting this at 5
percent and this thing is still,
you know, it's only got 1 year
left where the interest rate is
still 2 percent and the rest of
this is discounted at 5 percent
so it's starting to go down in
value.
So if you didn't have to mark
to market what would you do?
If you didn't have to declare
to the world what your present
value of your remaining assets
are,
because you could say,
"Oh,
it's so hard to figure out.
I don't know what the stuff is
worth, the present value of
what's going forward.
I just know the cash that's
coming in."
This carry trade would look
like a really good trade,
wouldn't it,
and a lot of people would do it
because then they would look--
the public would think that
they're doing really well
because they're getting positive
value,
but in the future that positive
value they're getting is just
disguising losses that are
happening in their portfolios
going forward.
So any questions about that?
Yeah?
Student: Can you explain
where their losses
>?
Prof: I want you to
explain it.
So I didn't calculate the
numbers.
It would have been better to do
actual numbers.
If we do 4,4,
4 at 5 percent interest,
or maybe I can do a--let's just
do a real number.
Well, let's just do the one
over here.
So this one is--no,
I can't do it,
because we've got 2 percent and
then 4 percent.
So we take a minute to do it on
Excel and we've seen how great I
am doing those on the fly.
So the point is that you agree
that this payment 4 is bigger
than 2.
So the first year if you buy
this bond and you sell that bond
you're going to have a positive
net 2 dollars.
However, it's perfectly
possible for this whole bond at
the beginning to be worth 100
the same as this bond at the
beginning.
Now, how could that be?
Well, the payments--4 is bigger
than 2 so how could this whole
thing have a higher present
value than this thing?
It has to be that starting at
period 1 the present value of
this 5 year bond (let's call it
this) in period 1 - the present
value of the 2 year bond staring
in period 1 has to be what?
If this present value of the 5
year bond,
this is the 5 year bond at time
0, equals 100,
and that's exactly the same as
this present value at time 0 of
the 2 year bond,
if that equals 100,
so the present value from the
beginning of this thing is the
same as the present value of
this thing from the beginning.
How could this thing have value
100?
Well, it's because it makes
lots of high coupon payments,
but the interest rate is going
to jump up in the future so
you're discounting all these
future cash flows at a big
number.
So all these things
present-valued could well equal
100.
So this could be 100 and this
could be 100 even though this is
paying off more at the beginning
than this thing is.
But what does that formula that
we just wrote down over there,
what does this formula tell us?
Where was this formula that I
wrote down?
This formula over here tells us
if the present values of two
instruments--
I see I wrote it for 1 bond,
but if you take 2 bonds with
the same present value,
one of which has a higher cash
flow in the first period than
the other,
then that formula tells you the
bond with the higher cash flow
at the beginning has to have a
bigger drop in the present value
than the other bond,
otherwise you can't get them
both equal to the same 100.
So this bond and this bond have
the same present value of 100.
Because this payment is bigger
than this payment,
but the present values are the
same,
100, it has to be that starting
from this point on,
this bond is worth less than
that bond.
So what happens?
You go long this bond,
you short that bond,
you say to the world,
"Ah ha!
I've made 2 dollars.
I'm a genius,"
and then you hide from them,
you might hide from them if you
didn't have to tell them,
they wouldn't know that the
present value of the bond you're
long going forward is actually
lower by 2 dollars than the
present value going forward--
this is right after this
period--the present value
starting at this point of this
bond going forward has actually
dropped 2 dollars below the
present value of this bond going
forward,
and it has to have dropped
otherwise the present values
wouldn't be the same.
So to just say it much more
simply,
if you take 2 bonds with the
same present value you could
well have that situation where
they have the same present value
because one of the bonds pays a
lot of stuff early and terrible
stuff late.
So in the beginning it looks
like this bond is paying you
more money than the other bond,
but since they have the same
present value it must mean that
this bond is going to pay you
more money at the tail than this
bond is.
That's why they had the same
present value.
So if one of them gets ahead at
the beginning it has to be it's
going to fall behind the rest of
the time.
So this one got ahead at the
beginning, it has to fall behind
the rest of the time.
That's hard to see because it
looks like this bond it's paying
a coupon that's always bigger
than that bond.
So it's easy to lose track of
the fact that this bond,
because its coupon is higher
than this bond,
how could it possibly ever fall
below this bond?
Well, it falls below because
it's longer and the cash flows
towards the end of it are being
discounted by an interest rate--
because everybody knows the
interest rate's going to go up.
And remember we saw last time
the yield curve.
The yield curve,
remember today's yield curve is
practically 0 now because the
government's held it at 0 and
it's going to go way up to 4
percent or something in a couple
years.
So that's the yield curve today.
So everybody knows the interest
rates are really low now and
they're going to get much higher
later.
So what it means is that every
long bond that's being issued
now is going to be issued with a
higher coupon than the short
bonds,
and if you go long the long
bond and short the short bond
you're going to make money at
the beginning but lose it back
later.
But if you don't have to report
mark to market,
you don't have to say the value
of what's left over,
the public's just going to see
that you're making money at the
beginning.
It's clear now?
Any other questions about this?
So a lot of this is going on
right now.
So let's do one more
application of this.
Let's explain how mortgages
work, one more idea.
Since the present value is = to
the cash flow the present value
at 1 times that,
given this formula,
that tells you one more thing,
very important idea.
How do you compute present
value 0?
Well, the way we've always
computed present value at 0 is
to do this calculation,
this long calculation
discounting all the future cash
flows,
but this formula tells you that
there's actually a more
efficient way of calculating it
by backward induction.
If I knew what the present
value was at time 1 then I could
get the present value at time 0
just by this formula.
I'd add the present value at
time 1 to the cash at time 1 and
discount it.
So in fact I don't have
to--now, I don't know the
present value at time 1,
but if I go to the end,
at the end of time,
I know the present value of the
bond is 0.
There's nothing coming up later.
At time T - 1 I know the
present value's very easy to
calculate.
It's C (T) divided by 1
i^(F)_T - 1.
So I can go backwards by
present value and compute.
I can do backward induction.
So that's the word I want to
describe which is going to play
a very important role in the
future of the class,
backward induction.
It says if this formula is
correct then a good way to do
the computation is by working
backwards from the end.
Don't just blindly take the
present value.
If you blindly take the present
value all you've got is
PV_0.
If I calculate by backward
induction I start to the end and
say, what would PV_T-1
be?
That's a really simple thing.
Then I can very simply find out
what PV_T-2 is
etcetera back to the beginning.
I do basically the same
calculation without having to
take powers of--
it's a shorter calculation
because here I've got exponents
of interest rates multiplying
each other.
So it's actually a shorter
calculation,
and on top of that I get much
more information because now
I've calculated out what the
present value's going to be at
every time period.
So a much more efficient way of
calculating things is to do it
by backward induction because it
also tells me more.
It tells me what the future
path of the bond is going to be.
So let's just see how that
works on an example that I hope
I worked out properly before.
Of course, I did it last year,
but let's assume I did it
right.
So let's take a mortgage,
if you can see this.
So this is something you have
in your notes.
So there's a mortgage.
Now, how does a--all right,
well pay no attention to that.
So let's just say that--oh no,
why did this happen?
Let's say that the payment is 8.
So I've made payments of 8
everywhere.
I hope I haven't screwed this
up.
So here's the mortgage.
It's a 30-year mortgage.
So these are the years 1,2,
3,4, 5,6, 7,
blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah up to year 30.
Now, suppose I happen to have a
bond that pays a coupon of 8
dollars every year,
and the interest rate,
let's say, is 7 percent.
So it would be the interest
rate on the mortgage,
but let's say the interest rate
in the economy is 7 percent and
the bond,
however, is a premium bond.
The bond is paying 8 percent
every year.
Now, this is a mortgage so what
does this mean?
See the mortgage pays 8 every
year until the very last year
where it's still paying 8.
So it's not paying 108,
it's just paying 8 every year.
So it's not a coupon bond.
It's a mortgage.
A mortgage pays the same amount
every year until the end.
So if this were a coupon bond
the last payment would be 108
and of course the thing would be
a tremendous--
it would be a premium bond
because the interest rate's only
7 because it would pay a higher
coupon of 8 and 108 at the end.
But you see I'm not paying 108
at the end.
I'm only paying 8 at the end.
So the first question is,
what is the present value of
this bond?
So I could take 8 divided by
1.07 8 divided by 1.07 squared
(all the way) 8 over 1.07 to the
thirtieth power and figure out
that number.
But a much better way of doing
it is by backward induction.
So what do I do?
I go to the end and I say this
line is the remaining balance.
Well, at year 30 there'd be no
more payments of the bond so the
present value of what's left is
obviously 0.
Now, what is the present value
of what's left at time 29?
Well, the only thing I'm going
to get is I'm going to get this
payment at time 8 right over
there.
Sorry.
I'm going to get this 8 right
there and so the present value
of 8 at 7 percent interest is
7.47, I mean,
7 percent interest.
So how did I figure that out?
I just said,
take that payment on the right
and discount it by 7 percent,
so it's 7.47.
Now, what's the present value
here?
Well, here you're going to get
two things.
What are you going to get?
You're going to get a coupon
payment.
Just after the payment in year
28 what's the present value of
what's left?
You're going to get a payment
in year 29 of 8 dollars.
You're also going to get one in
year 30, but you don't care
about that.
You just know that the value in
year 29 is the coupon you get in
year 29 plus the present value
in year 29 of what's left.
The PV at time t,
I can just put a t here,
PV at time t is the coupon you
get at time t 1,
the present value at time t 1
divided by the interest rate at
time t.
So all I have to do is take 8
7.47 and discount that by 7
percent, and that gives me the
present value as of time 28.
So if I go back to time 26 I
say, well, how do I figure out
the present value at time 27?
It's time 27.
I say, well,
I'm going to get 8 at time 28,
but the present value at that
time, just after that payment,
is 14.4.
So I take 22.4 and discount it
by 7 percent and I get about 21.
So that's how I can work
backwards and figure out the
present value today.
Now, in mortgages this number
is very interesting.
It's called the remaining
balance, which we'll see in a
second.
But anyway, that number you can
calculate it every t.
It's just the PV_t
worked backward from the end.
So it's a very simple
calculation and it tells you the
present value of the bond,
of that 8 percent coupon,
until year 30 and no principal
at the end.
Well, a mortgage has to pay a
coupon of 8 percent that gives
100 because if there were no
uncertainty and there are no
prepayments or anything,
no uncertainty,
the bank giving the coupon is
not going to give you money
unless its present value is
equal to 100.
So they're going to ask you to
pay a coupon.
So now you see what have I done
over here?
This is B 26 - B 30,
so the original face it was
supposed to be 100,
but the present value of all
those payments is only 99,
so there's a gap here of .72
and the square of the gap is
that.
The square of the gap is there,
and we want to minimize that.
So we're going to find the
payment every period,
Solver.
So I want to minimize B 32,
minimize by choosing B 29 which
looks good.
That's the first payment,
and all the other payments are
set to be equal to that,
to minimize that difference.
B 29 is the first payment,
so why didn't this work?
Student: You hardwired
in C 29 and D 29
>
Prof: Is that what I did?
So here's 8 and then this over
here.
I hardwired that in,
so I didn't want to do that.
So that's got to be equal to
what's left, equal,
left.
So here I got--when I hardwire
this then, okay,
so that's good.
So let's try the same thing now.
Tools, glad I have you guys,
Tools, so B 32 is what I'm
minimizing.
B 29 is the first payment and
all the others have been set
equal to it, and if I solve...
Student: C 29.
Prof: All right,
let's try.
The first payment is year 1,
right, so it should be--oh,
C 29, thank you.
Yeah, that's why I'm confused,
C 29, thanks.
Tools, so let's just look at
this a second.
So that's what I've hardwired
in.
So Format, no Tools, Solver.
Minimize B 32 subject to C 29
as you've told me 20 times,
C 29 and now solve.
So now we did it.
So we got the right payment to
make the balance exactly equal
to 100.
So that's how a mortgage works.
You have to find the coupon
payment such that if you take
the present value of that same
coupon payment forever it's just
going to be worth 100 which is
that number.
And how do you figure out the
coupon payment?
Well, you do it by backward
inductions.
Figure out the present value.
Do it by backward induction
just as we did.
But we've gotten a lot of
information.
We've gotten this number at
every period.
So by doing it by backward
induction instead of just doing
the long exponential
calculation,
by doing it by backward
induction we've produced the
present value at every time in
the future.
Now, that's an incredibly
important number in mortgages.
It's called the remaining
balance.
Why is that such an important
number in mortgages?
This will play a very key role
in the rest of the course.
What is the remaining balance
and why is it so important?
Does anyone know how a mortgage
works?
Yep?
Student: Is that the
mark to market value or just
whatever you'd be able to sell
that mortgage for to someone?
Prof: Not what you'd be
able to sell it for,
but close.
So when the bank gives you a
mortgage it says--so how did
mortgages work?
It used to be in the old days
that the mortgages were coupon
bonds.
They'd pay 8,8,
8,8, 8,108, and then what would
happen is just before the 108
payment everyone would default.
So in the Depression the people
who defaulted were people who
defaulted just before their big
principal payment,
so bankers got wise after the
Depression.
They said, "Well,
that's a terrible thing to do.
We should make the payment be
constant and that way there's no
reason for the guy to default
right at the end and we're not
going to get stuck with 100
dollars that's not paid."
So it's constant.
But of course if it's constant
that means the present value of
what's left is going down all
the time,
so that's why this number is
going down all the time.
If it's 108 at the end,
that's why the present value
would stay the same.
So it's going down all the
time, so that's why it's called
an amortizing mortgage.
It's because what's left in the
mortgage is getting smaller all
the time.
So a fixed rate mortgage pays
the same coupon every year.
The present value of what's
left, therefore,
must be going down every year
and that's why it's called
amortizing.
And bankers wanted that to
happen because that way their
risk is going down every year.
Every year the house is
presumably still worth 120 or
whatever it was at the beginning
and the amount owed is getting
lower and lower.
So the bankers are feeling more
and more secure every year
because the house is backing a
smaller and smaller loan,
or to put it another way,
if you're uncertain about what
the price of the house will be
in the future,
you want to make sure that what
is owed is going down in the
future.
If the price gradually goes
down of the house what's owed is
gradually going to go down.
But the main reason why the
number is so important is you
have to realize the purpose of a
mortgage is you take out a loan
using the house as collateral.
If you don't make your payment
they can take your house.
Well, what happens if you want
to move?
If you want to move you're
going to sell the house.
The house is no longer
collateral, so if you want to
move you have to undo the
promise to the bank.
So if in year 5 just after
you're making your payment of 8
dollars and 5 cents in year 5
you decide to move,
you say to the bank,
"I want to cancel the
mortgage."
How much will they ask you to
pay?
Well, the remaining balance,
93.91.
So that's why this remaining
balance is such an important
number.
So it allows people to leave
their house and pay off their
mortgage by paying off the
remaining balance.
You wouldn't want them to pay
100 if they left because they've
made payments.
You notice that the payment
here is 8 dollars.
That's bigger than 7 percent,
right, because if it's a coupon
bond you'd pay 7 all the way to
the end and pay 107.
That would have a present value
of 100.
If you're not paying the 100 at
the end,
but just making a level payment
all the way through,
the payment you have to make
every year better be more than
7,
so it's 8.
So this 8 - 7 is sort of what
you're paying down of your
mortgage, right?
The interest is only 7.
You've paid 8.
That's why you owe less than
100.
You've paid 1 dollar 6 extra.
That's why you only owe 98.94.
So every year you're paying
part of your principal down.
That means it's amortizing,
and that means if you want to
get out of the mortgage you can
get out of it by paying less and
less.
It means the lender,
the mortgage lender,
is more and more protected by
the house every year because
what you owe is less and less.
So that's how a mortgage works.
Any questions about that?
All right, so what's the point?
The point is that by simple
present value thinking you can
start to understand the main
instruments in the economy,
how mortgages work,
why they're called amortizing,
why the amount you have to pay
to get out of your mortgage goes
down every year,
and exactly how much it goes
down every year etcetera.
So we can do a lot more
examples like that,
but I want to change,
shift the discussion now to a
much bigger subject,
a subject of tremendous policy
interest in the country,
namely Social Security.
What should we do about Social
Security?
Now, it will turn out that you
can analyze the situation the
same way we've just analyzed
these bonds.
It's very simple to figure out
what the problem is and what
went wrong,
yet very few people understand
it, including most of our
politicians and,
I'm sorry to say,
a lot of our economists.
So I want to describe now in
the next class and a half the
Social Security problem and how
to solve the problem,
but also how to understand the
problem.
You can't figure out the right
solution until you've understood
what the problem is.
So were there any questions?
Before I start this,
were there any questions?
I should have paused.
Are there any questions about
the mortgage,
or present value,
or how present value changes
through time?
So those ideas,
and marking to market,
those are very important ideas
I think once you think about
them not so hard.
I'm now going to take exactly
those ideas and apply it to
Social Security where the public
is totally baffled,
but all you have to do is apply
the same thinking.
So Social Security is supposed
to be in a terrible crisis.
That's what they always tell
you.
It was a big campaign issue in
2000,
you probably were too young to
remember that,
but there were three debates
between Gore and Bush in which
Gore grimaced and everybody
thought he wasn't a good guy and
so they voted for Bush.
He was mostly grimacing about
Social Security.
And then in 2000--well,
I'll get to the future.
So anyway, in those debates
three mistakes were made.
So Bush argued that the returns
on Social Security were
disastrously low.
He said the whole program is in
a terrible crisis and we've got
to privatize to save the system.
How did it get into the crisis?
Well, it wasn't clear exactly
how it got into the crisis,
but it seems like the baby
boomers had something to do with
it.
They're all getting old and
they're going to have to get
these huge Social Security
payments,
and that's why we're in the
crisis because the baby boomers
are getting old.
It's all my fault,
or my generation's fault.
Then the third mistake was Gore
said, "Well,
it's impossible to
privatize."
Privatize means take the money
that your parents are paying in
Social Security and that you'll
start to pay;
instead of putting it into the
fund that's being used somehow,
you don't probably know exactly
how,
instead of doing that,
take that money and say it's
the taxpayer's money.
It's your money.
You can put it in the stock
market if you want.
So that's what Bush wanted to
do, privatize Social Security,
say your tax contributions
should go into a stock market
with your name on them.
And Gore said,
"Well, that's impossible.
If you privatize,
what are the old people today
going to do?
Where are they going to get the
payments?
You can't privatize Social
Security and take today's young
tax contributions to Social
Security and say,
'You young guys,
there's your money.
You can keep them in the stock
market,' and at the same time
pay the old retirees,
so Bush must not know what he's
talking about."
So that also was wrong.
So those three things,
that Social Security is going
to give terrible returns,
it must be it's wasting money,
something's horribly wrong with
it and the only way to save it
is to privatize it.
That's Bush's main claim.
Blame it all on the baby
generation,
that's everybody's claim,
and Gore saying you can't
privatize without screwing
today's young [correction:
today's retirees].
All three of those things sound
pretty convincing and yet
they're all three wrong.
So I want to explain the system
to you and help you understand
it,
and then I have a policy
recommendation you'll get next
class which most people don't
agree with,
so you probably won't either,
but I'll warn you when we get
to a point that's controversial.
So everything I'm going to say
in the first 90 minutes is going
to be uncontroversial.
Not everybody knows it,
but I think it's obviously just
a matter of logic.
And then my conclusion about
what to do, you can criticize
it.
I think it's a matter of logic
too, but I admit most people
don't agree with it.
So now, in 2005 if nothing else
Bush was tremendously
consistent.
So whatever he told you he was
going to do no matter how
wrong-handed it was he did it.
So he said in the debates that
he wanted to privatize Social
Security and sure enough he kept
his word.
He launched a huge program.
That's how he started right
after the 2004 election.
His first initiative,
you might remember,
was we've got to privatize
Social Security.
He went on a 60-day,
60-city tour to kick off his
second term.
So after the 2004 election
privatizing Social Security was
a huge issue.
In the 2008 election it was
still a big issue.
McCain said sort of what Bush
said.
"I want young workers to
be able to if they choose,
to take part of their own money
which is their taxes,
their money that's getting
taxed and getting put into
Social Security,
I want them to have their own
account and put it into the
stock market with their name on
it."
And Obama said he's totally
against that.
That was 2008.
Recently, of course,
the public has made another
mistake.
So everybody is saying now,
"Oh, the financial crisis.
We better not talk about Social
Security anymore."
Nobody's talking about Social
Security.
They're saying, "Well,
could you have imagined what
would have happened had we
privatized as Bush wanted us to
do and the stock market
collapsed?
Everybody would have lost all
their money.
What a disaster that would have
been, and it would have ruined
the old."
This sounds pretty persuasive.
So Krugman wrote a column
saying, "A bullet dodged.
What would have happened if
Bush had succeeded?
All the old people would be
broke now."
And Robert Reich who was in the
Clinton Administration sort of
more or less said the same thing
that it'd be a disaster.
Now, the Obama Administration,
by the way, hasn't stopped
talking about Social Security.
So their director,
he's the Director of the White
House Office of the Budget,
so this is an incredibly
important position,
Peter Orszag.
He's the son of--there's a math
professor here,
Orszag, his father.
So he's a friend of mine,
the son.
He said once healthcare reform
is in place the U.S.
can then focus on other
important things,
especially Social Security.
So Obama wants to do something
about it, but he just doesn't
want to privatize.
So it's a big problem and
everything everybody says about
it seems plausible.
Now, just to continue along the
plausibility of it,
so Bush says what he really
wants to do is--
why private accounts are a
better thing is that if you put
the money in private accounts it
can grow.
You can get a greater rate of
return than the current system
which is terrible.
If you were a young person by
putting your Social Security tax
money aside in a private account
you'll be able to get a better
rate of return on your money
than the government could get
you on your money.
So why would you just want to
give it to the government?
It's for your retirement and
you'll be able to pass that
money along to your children and
grandchildren if you want at the
end.
And best of all the money's
yours and the government can't
take it away.
So that's what Bush says and
he's said many times.
So there's one sense in which
he's right.
So let's look at the returns
people got on Social Security.
Now, what is a return?
We know what the rate of return
is.
How do they calculate it?
You can go back to people born
starting in 1878.
Social Security,
as you'll see in a second,
I'm going to give you the
history, began 1939.
So these people in 1878 they're
60 when Social Security's
beginning, if my arithmetic is
right.
So they're 60 at that point.
So you can look at all these
people and you can say,
for every generation in the
past, you can say how much money
did they pay when they were
young?
They paid taxes.
So they got negative 12.4,
that's the tax rate.
Negative 12.4,
they did that a bunch of years
when they were young and then
they started getting payments
when they were old,
24,24, 20 something like that.
Those are the payments when
they're old.
So there are negative ones at
the beginning and positive ones
at the end.
You can calculate the internal
rate of return,
the yield, the thing that makes
this present value 0.
We know how to do that.
We've done it.
So people have done this.
So there's a guy named Limmer,
Limmer or Leemer from the
Social Security Administration
who did these calculations,
prompted a little bit by me.
So I should say that a lot of
the reason I got started
thinking about this is I got put
on a Presidential Panel to study
Social Security Reform in the
Clinton Administration and every
Democrat was matched with a
Republican.
So the two chairmen,
one Democrat,
one Republican,
all the way along there was
Democrat and Republican,
and after Bush got elected all
the Democrats got kicked off the
committee.
But anyway, so in any case here
are the rates of return.
For people who are old when the
program began,
they got sensational rates of
returns, 40 percent,
30 percent, incredible rates of
return.
As the generations get younger
and younger the returns go lower
and lower and they're down now
to 2 percent.
These are a forecast of these
rates of returns.
And so let's see,
you're 20, say,
something on average.
You were born in 1990,
something like that or around
there.
So here's your rate of return.
It's down here, right?
It's 2 percent,
and there it is blown up.
It's under 2 percent.
So these are the people from
1924 to 2002,
so you're right at the end
here.
That's your rate of return
blown up.
You can only expect 1 and a
half or 2 percent.
So George Bush is right.
The rate of return on Social
Security is terrible.
If you look at the taxes that
you put in, and you look at the
benefits that you can expect to
get your generation is getting
totally screwed.
So now if you look
historically--this was done in
1994,
so the number's a little
bit--it's not quite as dramatic,
but it hasn't changed as much
as you think.
From money put in the stock
market between '26 and 2004,
that's before the crash of '29,
so I should have gotten the
number after the recent crash.
It doesn't change that much.
Before the crash of '29 you
looked at keeping your money in
the stock market,
just leaving it there for all
that time,
after inflation you'd get 9.1
percent return.
On treasury bonds you get 2.7
percent return and yet on Social
Security you're going to get
under 2 percent.
So George Bush says,
"Look, put it in the stock
market.
Get 9 percent."
We had a little disaster here,
so maybe it's 7 percent.
"Put it in the stock
market and get 7 percent.
Why be satisfied with 2 percent?
There's something wrong.
We've got to privatize,
put an end to this."
So there seems to be something
to what he is saying.
So now you look at what's going
on with Social Security.
So what happens in Social
Security?
I'm going to explain the whole
history and how it works here.
What happens is you pay taxes,
12.4 percent tax.
You probably know that.
Everybody's paying taxes on the
money they make and then there
are benefits that are being
paid.
Now, the benefits are
not--there's a formula for
benefits which doesn't have
anything to do with the amount
of taxes being paid,
so at the present time the
taxes are bigger than the
benefits.
So where does the extra money
go?
It goes into the Social
Security Trust Fund.
So here's the Social Security
Trust Fund which is now around 2
trillion,
which is going to keep growing
because contributions are going
to be bigger than benefits until
2020 or so,
and at that point
contributions--that's the baby
boom generation,
that's me retiring,
or a little later in my case,
but anyway the baby boom
generation--
in fact since I'm a Yale
professor it's out here
somewhere.
So anyway, my generation's
going to start retiring here and
then the benefits--
so we're going to be not
working, not paying taxes but
we're collecting benefits and
there are so many of us that the
benefits are going to be less
than the taxes and the trust
fund's going to go down,
and down, and down.
And then the year 2030,
at a little bit more than 2030,
the trust fund's going to go to
0, and then after that the taxes
are still going to be smaller
than the benefits.
And so what's going to happen?
They'll be no money to pay
these people and there's going
to have to be a big drop in what
people are getting.
So it looks like the system is
not only paying a horrible rate
of return, it's not even going
to pay.
It's going to run out of money
and go broke in 2040.
So it seems like a total
disaster.
So that's the setting of the
question.
George Bush said it's a
disaster.
It looks, at first glance,
like a disaster.
The newspapers tell you all the
time it's a disaster.
How did it get to be so bad and
what should we do about it?
All right, now it's going to
turn out that by using the
concept of present value it can
be very simple and
straightforward to understand,
and it's going to be the exact
opposite of what everybody seems
to be saying.
So I'm going to play you a clip
next time of Roosevelt
announcing the Social Security
program and this lady behind him
is Frances Perkins,
the first woman to ever be in
the Cabinet,
and she played a tremendous
role in shaping Social Security.
So after Roosevelt started
Social Security in 2004--I'm
wondering whether I really have
time to do this,
so I'll just say this.
So Roosevelt started the
program in 1938-'39.
He started the program in
'38-'39.
It was one of the cornerstones
of the New Deal.
It's an incredibly famous
program and it seems to be in
incredible trouble.
So we need to find out and get
to the bottom of why that is and
we'll start doing that next
class.